travis walton is a purported ufo
abductee he's widely considered in the
ufo community to have one of the most
credible stories of ufo abduction though
this is of course a contentious issue
the incident happened in 1975 where him
and his colleagues were working in the
woods in arizona when a ufo came shawn
light down terrifying everyone and
everyone except travis managed to escape
he was found five days later a few days
ago i was lucky enough to host an ask me
anything live stream with travis where i
asked questions from the audience as
well as soliciting questions from reddit
for those new to this channel my name is
kurt j mungle i'm a filmmaker with a
background in mathematical physics
particularly on the theoretical ends and
i'm interested in what's called a theory
of everything or theories of everything
in general now that means the
investigation into the fundamental laws
of the universe there seems to be a
connection there between consciousness
free will god even and theoretical
physics there aren't many scientists who
are interested in exploring the ufo
topic at least publicly unless it's to
dismiss that they're genuine craft from
a non-tellurian source or at least to
lurian in the sense that we understand
it so let's say the inhabitants of the
countries as far as we know there are
some people like richard dolan who think
perhaps it's a breakaway civilization
but that's beside the point it's
flattering and humbling that even though
i'm a fledgling in this topic the
community has been extremely kind to me
the ufo community so for example the
reddit community including people like
jeremy riss from alien scientist or
stephen cambion from truth seekers
they're far more knowledgeable than i am
and i cared like clay in comparison to
their nuance and specificity as far as
actual scientific professors
investigating this topic publicly
there's only one and that's my friend
professor brian keating who sponsored
today's video brian's into the
impossible podcast is the only other
place where you can consistently find
rigorous interviews with nobel laureates
on the topic of experimental physics as
well as recently on the topic of ufo
slash uaps he's a member of avilob's
galileo project in search of
technological signatures of alien life
throughout the cosmos and soon brian
keating and i will be speaking to tom
delong on brian's podcast it will be a
live stream ama as well so make sure to
subscribe to brian's podcast links are
in the description if you want to see
that the next sponsor is algo which is
an end-to-end supply chain optimization
software company headed by amjad hussein
who i've mentioned frequently on this
podcast as one of the first if not the
first supporter of the podcast i thought
it'd be great if you all could get to
know him in the same way that i do given
this i interviewed amjad and i'm going
to be including little five-minute
snippets into the ends of several
episodes including this one stick all
the way to the end if you want to hear a
conversation between amjad and myself
about ufos the last sponsor is brilliant
brilliant illuminates the soul of math
science and engineering through
bite-sized interactive learning
experiences brilliance courses explore
the laws that shape our world elevating
math and science from something to be
feared to a delightful experience of
guided discovery more on them later
thank you and enjoy
okay if you can see this type bulbasaur
bulbasaur
say again
no not you
the audience i'm just making sure that
it's live streaming now so that i don't
have technical difficulties on my end
okay travis we'll start with how are you
doing man how was your day
i'm doing okay it's a we've had a huge
rainstorm here is kind of flooding the
street but
all i got was wet feet
the first question is
why is it that you think you've seen so
many ufos because most people go their
entire life without seeing a single one
do you think you're tracked all right
well that's a good question but uh
it i think it has to do with um
living in a
remote area
living an outdoor lifestyle
uh
clear skies the weather's ideal for
seeing whatever's up there so many
people say oh i've never seen anything
like that and i say well have you ever
looked up and they kind of him and hall
about that but i mean i see a wonderful
panorama of stars every every night when
i walk to the car or whatever you know
i i would never want to imply that they
have an interest in me or or something
like that but uh
um
i i really don't think that uh
multiple
sightings are that
rare when i look around and you know
just inquire with casual people people
who aren't into this paranormal or ufos
or anything
and
seems like everybody's had sightings
not everybody reports them but
it's not that uncommon
this question comes from sa keeb ali he
wants to know what is one thing about
the incident that you haven't talked
about because you don't like talking
about it
well there's a number of things that um
i
like to steer clear of you know
interviewers just love to
zero in on the most terrifying parts and
naturally
uh those are the parts
uh you know to actually recount what i
was feeling at that time
after 45 years
i still rather not go there
do you have ptsd from it
i think so yeah i was surprised to the
the degree to which i do
you know
having this
other siding that we sort of
uh alluded to earlier
uh
coming back from um
a mufon meeting in burbank california
um
heading up to five
this giant black triangle came stopped
right over the top of the car
turned and headed off to the west
incredible uh ability to decelerate and
accelerate
um
it um
it was still something that i wouldn't
have ever brought up in an interview or
anything like that except that uh i was
able to find out that it was uh
seen by
about 15 other people
or at least reported by that many people
by the next morning
so certainly over
uh a highly populated area like that
um there were many many more people who
saw it but uh
just didn't know where to report it
i recall that you have had an experience
with a ufo somewhere on
route i5 or road i5 or highway i5
and it had to do with a pregnant
girlfriend at the time
do you mind recounting that
yeah it's the same sighting and uh yes
so
um she was with me she was
and so was my son and what happened
well um
it's in her estimation uh there was um
missing time uh you know it seemed to
take a lot longer
uh to get home than it should have uh
you know accounting for time differences
and whole
the whole thing but uh
again i've always uh tried to avoid
reporting things uh i can't corroborate
everything has to be done they're
missing time on your part or only she
reported that
to you
well i agree with her you know
her estimations and comments about it
but
um
by itself it doesn't constitute proof
and it's just something we
find very interesting and your son
also experienced missing time or time
dilation
um
he doesn't disagree he's just you know
how would you know you know on a long
drive like that all the way from burbank
to north lake arizona
um
how do you know for sure was there
something about your girlfriend at the
time was pregnant and then after the
sighting she became not pregnant and it
was because of alien interference i
don't know if i'm reading that from by
surmising from the questions or if i've
read or heard that somewhere
well boy that is something i i don't
really bring out that much because you
know
she works in a
government facility and um
you know has a security clearance and uh
um
i really don't have her permission to
talk about that or name her or whatever
but yeah
um
she had a mark across her stomach i went
into the
gynecologist's office with her i
observed on the ultrasound
um
that um
there was a placenta a cord
and the
fetus said just disappear
why do you think that is
i don't know
um the one speculation of is obviously
that uh
the the baby was taken by you know some
alien technology another alternative
is uh medically speaking
some kind of a thing where they claim
that a baby can be reabsorbed but if
that were really true you would think it
would affect the cord and a placenta too
but
it didn't
i know that you have intuitions or
feelings that these
beings were being helpful toward you
given that do you think yes
i'm wondering
i think
go ahead yeah i'm just wondering okay
how was the removal of a fetus
positive unless
maybe the baby would have been born
cancerous or
have some other issue
so i'm curious if you don't mind
i'm sure you've thought about this do
you mind letting us know your
speculations well uh obviously the
theory is uh you know that uh
we conjecture that the baby is alive
somewhere it was just taken
uh for a more nurturing
environment
uh with really super super high tech i
guess uh the woman's body is not
absolutely necessary
um that's the theory how far along was
she in the pregnancy
um
i i
in days i i don't know
i i don't have that uh on the tip of my
tongue
was it within a month or was it within
six months
plus or minus a month or you have no
record oh it wasn't uh a very large uh
amount of development you know
lose clothing she probably could have
disguised the fact that she was pregnant
do you regret that the abduction
happened do you wish it didn't
absolutely oh i wish
i wish i'd never gotten out of that
truck uh
just
not not a big positive in my life
or even in those
who that i care about
not positive with respect to the press
and the accusations or
or the ptsd or what
all of the above including just that uh
the topic never escapes you know
it's just to live a normal life react to
normal things be interested in things
um
it's even hard to be
too under the weather now
under the radar uh what i mean was
that
to be recognized everywhere you go is
some people think would be pretty cool
but uh
not really do people come up and try to
take pictures with you
all the time i get people knock on my
door
hello i'm in town
i know you live here
could i trouble you for
an autograph and a picture
is this okay so right now i'm sure
you're considered
your identity as the ufo person at least
as far as other people are concerned is
there something else you'd like to be
known for
do you have another hobby no just
dad grandpa
uh something other than that guy
okay high priest of galvin of gavin
almighty asks
has he ever done dmt and how does that
compare to his experience in the 80s
which i believe he means 70s
what's what's dmt it's a psychedelic oh
oh oh yeah that's a chemical
spirit molecule no never
any
psychoactive substances like let's say
cannabis or lsd
or mushrooms um
50 years ago um about a handful of times
okay 50 years ago was about the 70s was
it 1975
no uh it would be in in the late 60s uh
early 70s
it was just uh
altered states were not
um
is uh you know i i always strive for the
greatest reality the greatest
here and now
rather than altered states it's just
it's a preference of mine i don't i
i'm such a stick in the mud i don't
really even enjoy alcohol you know it's
just
same i don't drink at all actually
when it comes to psychedelics
there's obviously a connection between
psychedelics and consciousness and there
seems to be some tenuous or maybe even
direct connection between consciousness
and these entities whatever we want to
call them aliens or whatever
do you see that and if so
what is that connection
i think it's just basically simple
telepathy it's inevitably where
uh communication will go for humans
i think
uh to to a great extent people already
experience this phenomenon
some in a much more highly developed
way than others
and i think for beings that are
always being described as being
emotionless and cold
to me that is merely a sign that facial
expressions have become obsolete for
them uh they're they're going to
communicate a greater richness of what
they mean
inflections and emotion and all that and
no need to have
anything represented by
uh
muscles on their face contorting in
certain ways it really is kind of an
unusual thing because i think humans are
pretty much the only critters that
communicate that way there's all kinds
of things that animals
do to communicate in terms of
sounds and
posture and sorts of things but i think
for advanced consciousness
uh
telepathy is inevitable
johnny 80 asks
the abduction happened around 1975 and
our technology was still primitive at
the time during your time inside the
ship what kind of devices or interfaces
got your attention what did the light
sources look like were there any screen
or any
thing that displays images
oh yeah there was a great deal of uh
of that sort of thing that i wasn't
there
uh gee whiz wow this is amazing i was
terrified it was out of my mind how do i
get out of this thing how do i escape
was my main focus so
so
most of the um
you know
um
interest in these kinds of things
occurred in retrospect you know looking
back on
uh
things i saw and interpreting them
the best i could
is there anything now that
much technology has been developed in
the past 40 years
whereas before you wouldn't recognize
what a cell phone was
maybe it wouldn't be conspicuous to you
or just wouldn't register but now you
have that so now thinking back given our
technology is there something that you
recognize that when you were there you
didn't but now you have this linguistic
tool set of modern technology
yeah um and maybe things beyond still
where we are you know
what was i described as a screen
had intersecting lines
but no characters and that's really
strange how would they know what was
what as far as these
gradations meant it's all speculation
is it all right if i ask you some
questions about the screen
well
like
like i'm saying i was just
desperate to find a way to open the door
and escape this thing uh
i wasn't musing about what this means it
was a
just
a glowing surface kind of like a
computer but um
black lines
with little
short
black lines on each of those but at
angles
and these
angles would change and they would slide
in response to
me touching this uh surface
i i took to be buttons it was some
colored areas on the surface
i don't remember have you ever mentioned
this before i was looking at some of
your interviews i don't recall this
well i might have just referred to them
as buttons of your this is much more in
depth in that area than i've ever
encountered
have you ever drawn it before
um
no
i worked with an artist who just
gave a more distant shot
angle of um
um you know like from the door from a
distance
okay so
am i to understand at this point you
were lying down when you saw the screen
no no i was wandering around
desperately seeking a way out
okay so from what i understand just
correct me if i'm wrong you were you
woke up
being
finding it difficult to breathe someone
put a mask on you that didn't seem to be
attached to anything it also calmed you
at some point someone who looked human
appeared to you
and i believe they started taking you
out of this smaller room into a larger
one is that correct
oh
well no
that's pretty all jumbled together you
know i woke up um
and very
great deal of pain
um
when i could finally focus and see these
creatures standing over me i realized no
i
hadn't been hurt and sent to a hospital
but uh
i was taken out of this craft by
human-looking beings
to this larger room and
smaller room off of that
um
that's where the mask was applied but
that was basically just designed to uh
put me out make render me unconscious
there are three rooms in total there's
the one that you were initially in the
one that you exited and it was much
larger and you said there was an
algorithm that's a vast over
simplification i was inside the craft
when i finally exited that it was at
that point parked inside of this huge
we'll call it a room it could be a
building or part of a larger craft
and then taken out of this big huge
hangar-like area
uh down a hallway to the room where i
was rendered unconscious
were you able to see outside the craft
what color were the walls if there were
walls
um the
i
i took the
um
lighted areas
in the big hanger-like area to be
sunlight being filtered through some
kind of uh
frosted surface but it also could have
been um
synthetically or you know
produced artificially produced uh
something to duplicate sunlight
just uh
not super intense but you just have to
light the area
you also just mentioned that you were
working with an artist
did the artist draw those lines on the
screen that you were referring to about
five minutes ago
well i described it to him but uh the
overall lay of the room and
you know
the the the screen and the surfaces that
it was mounted on all that was
you know a
a 20 feet away sort of perspective not
down over my shoulder watching my hand
kind of perspective that's what i was
trying to tell you
okay we have a question here from
steve cambion
he wants to know have you ever had an
association with dr roger lear
yes i i
met dr roger lehrer and
considered him a friend he's no longer
with us but
uh i did not do any work in terms of
searching for
the kind of work he specialized in
uh and that being because i'd already
had
um
upper body x-rays uh
from uh
dr kandel
and enough nothing was um
noted in the x-ray
a tiny dot in one lung they called it a
granuloma but uh
it probably was just a granuloma
i've had other chest x-rays since then
that didn't comment on such a thing but
at the time there could have been some
you know
um
resolving effect from you know a prior
uh
respiratory infection or something
it wasn't considered real significant at
the time
do you recall the state of your clothes
when you came to and you were found
i believe it was near to the location
that you were picked up from
yeah um my clothing looked pretty much
the way it did at the time being hit
with that blast of energy the first
thing that we naturally look for was was
there any burn marks or anything like
that but there wasn't
but uh my brother was uh
he'd had some advice from people who had
uh contacted him at the site
to preserve the clothing if i was
returned so he did have me take that off
i changed my clothes these were placed
in a clean
plastic bag
and sealed up
but uh the
planned uh forensic analysis
kind of went by the way because there
was so much
um
turmoil and
just crazy stuff going on
it was sort of forgotten it was in the
trunk and the bag got uh things thrown
in on top of it toward open
and it was considered contaminated at
that point
and uh it wasn't pursued there was a lot
of other things uh
commanding attention at the time
someone here mike mcdonald said what's
what's the secret behind the mustache
my upper lip
many people here are saying thank you
they
admire what you're doing and they
applaud your courage
well i would like something
good to come of it um
working on it you know to begin with i
want people to know that this is uh a
real phenomenon and that i think much of
the fear
or fear-mongering
unnecessary much of what hollywood has
done is um
you know
invading monsters kind of an approach
uh
i encountered beatings that were clothed
and
of course in hollywood they're always
completely unclothed so you can see the
monstrous nature of their of their
physical bodies
speaking of the aliens physical
characteristics roger mobby
or mobby wants to know did the aliens
have a face with a nose and a mouth
yes in this case uh i imagine there's
varieties out there but
i would say the nose and the mouth are
probably have similar functions to us
other than perhaps speaking maybe maybe
they sing i don't know
did you happen to watch the ufo incident
i believe that's a film about barney and
betty hill did you happen to watch that
prior to the
yeah years years later
i i saw a little bit of it you know
not the whole thing but
and i had
was actually introduced to betty hill
on the phone by uh dr harder
what i'm curious about is did you happen
to watch it or see the trailer or know
of it prior to your experience
prior to the abduction no
no i i was not aware of that and you
know of course that was one of the first
things that skeptics want to say is oh
he saw the movie uh or tv show or
whatever it was and was inspired to
reenact it but that's that's not true
okay some of these names i don't know
what they're about so if you don't mind
enlightening me steve cambion from truth
seekers also wants to know in the latest
news with mike rogers confessing a hoax
so i'm unclear who mike rogers is
why has
none of the rest of your crew spoken up
on your behalf
well they they have and they all insist
that you know what we saw
we saw what happened happened
and even mike rogers is uh
in the same supposed quote confession
said there i think there is no way this
could have been a hoax well this is a
narrative that's being pushed by a
filmmaker a wannabe filmmaker
truth is he
has no track record no resume but uh
he's the one that's uh designed this
whole scheme to try to
induce mike to
say things that he could use in this
regard
to support the idea that
the crew didn't really see a craft
in the woods that somehow they wound up
miles away
by
a fire watch tower that the forest
service had and that what they really
saw was this fire tower which is just
totally nonsense it's laughable to see
the picture of that and say oh you're
going to mistake that for a glowing disc
you know this thing is on a
sturdy metal
framework structure holding it up
and um
i was standing underneath this thing
there was no
steel legs or any such thing and it's
just
it's it's a real stretch to try
to to claim this somehow the crew didn't
realize they spent another 15 minutes
driving to where this would be or
something
it's it's laughable when you look at all
of the um
deliberate
misrepresentations that have been made
mike rogers
is being cred a claim that he made a
confession
he says and has said a number of times
since then no
i did not say that
this happened just exactly as we
described it who is mike rogers one of
your friends who was there oh he was the
crew boss he was driving the truck that
night uh taking the whole all seven of
us home that night and you mentioned
that there's a filmmaker involved
oh he calls himself a filmmaker but like
i say he has no no resume no
no history of ever having made a film
um he's really really kind of a strange
character
no
no permanent address no you know he just
drives around in a new rv and
just mysteriously encountered mike at
the site just a wild coincidence
mike was there you know doing something
for mufon and he just happens to run
into mike
but
mike's got some health problems and
struggles with um
um
movement and um
the site is a couple of thousand feet
higher than where he lives
so um
there's a there's a was a great deal of
uh strain just just being there
on mike rogers
and uh
this supposed confession was
uh
made over a phone
uh
and
leading sorts of
suggestions to
uh
to me it's not clear at all i i would
in
in reviewing all of the lies of blatant
lies that this
supposed filmmaker made
uh in the course of this whole operation
just flat out provable just
concoctions out of thin air
i would uh take mike's uh
description of things
over his in spite of the fact that i've
had quite a falling out with him in
terms of uh
other kinds of uh
um
things that he's uh
come to his spouse in his
waning years
you have to elucidate me because i don't
know the relationship between this
filmmaker and you and mike so is this
filmmaker someone who is interested in
doing a documentary or a film on
something comes
well that was that was the supposed uh a
year before all this
um i had
a few conversations with him about
making a documentary
and i told him no i'm not going to do
anything with you and cut it off and i
gave him largely my reason is this
ridiculous
um
fire tower uh theory that he was so
anxious to
uh find support for
but um one lie that he tells is that i
was
in deep discussions with him about
a big budget remake of fire in the sky
i never would have done that that's
ridiculous
uh i have all the
email exchanges at the time and the
nothing of the sort was said
and i've turned down a number of people
you know we just fly by night filmmakers
and say i'll do that i'll do the remake
and uh
i wasn't looking for uh somebody that
wanted to just kind of do something and
capitalize on
the fame of the incident but somebody
who really seriously wanted to do a
better remake
and uh a group of people
who have those qualifications contacted
me recently they called me
uh you know i've put it out there for
quite some time that i would like to see
a remake of the movie but
this wannabe guy uh
concocted a pretty elaborate
scheme
to uh
provoke these things uh
in mike who
you know he's not as good of health as
he has been in the past he was very
vigorous uh high performing it did
you know performed very well in
the logging festivals and those kinds of
things but he's had a couple of strokes
and uh some other medical issues that i
you know
respect his privacy
um
and um
i i i tell him i think he's delusional
uh he angrily rejects that theory but i
think this wannabe guy was taking
advantage
of
mike's um
let's call it
varying states of uh
and
to try to push this narrative because he
wanted to be the guy that was going to
tear it all down because it was really
um
the gentry tower fire lookout uh
miles away from there it's just totally
ridiculous
is this a filmmaker jeremy corbell
no
can you say who the filmmaker is
um
why would i want to make him famous
that's what he's here for
um
i have a nickname for him sure his first
name
rhymes with lion
because he's always lying but other than
that i'm not gonna yeah
okay well i have a question here about
ryan and i assume then it's the same
person the question is in a phone call
with ryan
you said this is what this person is
saying this is what steve campion is
saying
you said someone else was posting on
your facebook on your behalf so who is
this person that's the question
well that was just speculation about
people uh going online and pretending to
be me i mean that's ridiculous how often
that happens
imposters that's all i'm not there
wasn't any some particular thing that
was being discussed you know i had
some strange people over the years
people claiming to be
other than who they were
someone claiming to be the sheriff's
nephew
i talked to the sheriff about it and uh
didn't know who this could possibly be
claiming to know my kids and their
cousin
they don't know who it could possibly be
but he was making ridiculous claims
that he had the inside story people do
this all the time there's something big
in the news and i live in this area so
i'll make up some
connection to this
to gain attention so he said when they
recovered my me from the phone booth
that my stomach was covered with dirty
needle marks
this is to suggest that the whole thing
was a drug hallucination
um
i actually had a um
thorough medical examination a number of
examinations
by a number of doctors
right after that
and blood and urine samples were
submitted to the maricopa county medical
examiner's drug screen
showed no trace of any drug
and of course the doctor examined uh my
naked body and there was no such marks
on me it was just a way to claim
uh some connection to something there's
a whole bot a bunch of other stuff that
he was claiming that were just
uh about
where allen lived
you know
that he lived in concho which is a
quarter mile from snowflake
i mean this guy didn't even know the
geography of the area and he's a faking
faking life after life but you know what
so many people online spotted his lies
they were jumping before i even found
out he existed
but there's other connections other
people that um you know
some some a little bit more benign some
friendly you know there was a guy that i
was friends with
that said because he lived in heber
that when i made that phone call that
night for my family to rescue me
that i called him first and he wasn't
home so then i called my family
um
that's
an impossible set of priorities there
and
it's totally
falsified by the fact that when i called
it was a collect call i had no money on
me
uh the operator listened in on the call
and reported to the sheriff
and the sheriff sent officers over there
that night
so
there was only one call made and it was
just
a kind of a
somebody trying to be important you know
i know this guy and
you know there were another a few other
claims that uh oh here's one
i worked with travis on the loud landing
and
every morning when he'd come in
he'd take off his hard hat and line it
with fresh aluminum foil
basically saying travis is a tennis oil
hat guy and uh this is totally i never
worked with
this guy on any log landing anywhere and
uh there were never any tinfoil in my
hard hat
a few people here are saying
that i never doubted you travis that's
memo type
someone else is saying
well there's many plaudits in the
comments i can't get to them all well i
appreciate that and i i would like to
say thank you to those people
archer emissary of gorgonites asks
is he familiar with the skinny bob
videos the alien leaked footage and if
so did his abductors look like that
i have heard that term and uh i
to the best of my knowledge i i don't
think um
that description matches
it's you know people say oh they were
the grays you know
it might be that
sentient humanoids will tend to go in
that direction
it wouldn't surprise me to learn
that
what's called the grays could actually
be separate species you know even coming
from different places
although
you know end up looking very similar
debt wodify wants to know if you recall
any distinctive smells from the
spacecraft
well that's a pretty common question but
um the only thing i remember about odors
especially when i first woke up was um
just the feeling of suffocation i
couldn't get enough air
and um
um the feeling that something was very
wrong inside something
um
i like uh i was suffocating and that the
air was
um
probably less oxygenated but certainly a
lot more humid than
normal
jackson vega wants to know what do you
think of stephen greer
um never met him
i've even been places where he was also
appearing but
i
basically keep to myself
all the time anyway and
and he never uh
saw me out so never had a conversation
with him
what are some of the people that you
consider to be most credible see for me
i'm a novice in this field and i don't
know who to trust who not to trust so i
approach each person with an open mind
and i assume what they're saying is true
and i just talk to them as if they're
being honest
but obviously some people are misleading
and
i don't have enough experience i'm
unclear if you can get enough experience
to be able to discern what's
misinformation
but
either way who do you consider to be the
credible people or some credible people
well i agree that not all you hear at
events or things that are made public
are on the same
type of
plane is what
we experienced
um
i i think in in some cases they're just
outright lies but in many cases these
are people who have had some sort of
very
vivid experience that they truly believe
but
probably didn't actually happen
but
i that would be so presumptuous you know
how many people passed judgment on me
without having investigated my case
happens constantly
they they're they're so poorly versed
they they jumbled on the on the details
but yet they're attacking uh they made
up their minds before they even look at
the facts so i never wanted to be guilty
of that to
um
say who's authentic and who's not just
on base of my impression i definitely do
have those kinds of impressions there
are some people that i believe have
definitely had authentic
they're
really recounting things that happened
to them
and others
perhaps not but but
i've made a policy of not pointing to
which ones are
good and which ones aren't
what led you to believe that the people
who are good are good
like what are you picking up on or is it
subtle body language is it something
that they say that's consistent with
your experience that only those in the
know
no many many things
goes into that you know it's kind of
just the same way you and i size each
other up when we have a conversation you
know um
there are some people you can tell
that they are um
for varicators in a kind of a way they
look at reality in a way that feeds
their
self-esteem
um
these people are called narcissists
a narcissist
is a form of mental illness
but it's really quite common and quite
destructive
but um when people hear the term
narcissist they think of
uh oh well
the old greek legend or whatever it was
that where the name came from
it was supposedly
um
some character in mythology who just
uh was entranced by his own image in in
the mirror and the reflection
well no narcissism has is kind of a
sickness of uh
uh
floundering self-esteem
that can be extremely
dangerous
and
when when you say somebody's delusional
they think you're talking about somebody
who sees pink elephants in the room or
is
mindlessly jabbering
um
incoherently
but
no people uh
that are of an
mental
illness of this sort
uh can be
very good at um
making things
fit the narrative you know
they they have um
paranoid delusions that people are
plotting against them or the things
occurred
in the basis of no evidence at all but
it's uh they're totally convinced by it
because
uh they need to believe it for various
psychological reasons
and uh
potentially very harmful uh mental
condition
travis is there any aspect about the
1975 case that you can't talk about for
some reason such as the government told
you don't talk about this aspect or that
it breaches confidentiality of a friend
some reason you can't talk about it
besides the personal pain
yes and for that reason i'm not going to
talk about it but you know i just don't
want to uh compromise people who are
supposed to keep secrets that confided
you know
that's what the word confided means you
know i they take me into their
confidence and
and i'll i'll try to
um abide by that
respect that
so what i'm wondering is i'm sure there
are aspects like you might just mention
that you can't talk about now one of
those reasons is because of
because you made an oath to a friend
perhaps
can you talk about why you can't talk
about it rather than talking about it
well if they're in a position where
they're sworn to secrecy if they are um
uh
um what's the term um
i can't think of the word it starts with
a c
um
um you know when you uh
take an oath in in the military or some
other official organization
um
certain things or
some types of information
are
off limits and uh there's a word for
that and i'm just kidding
by the way anyone who's watching right
now can you please send me the link to
the skinny bob video then i'll send it
to you travis and you can respond over
email if it looks similar because i
don't think you've seen the video
is that correct that you haven't seen
this you've only heard about the skinny
bob video
are you showing me the video no no no
i'm asking you have you seen the video
or have you only heard about the video
uh i may have but i think it's something
very vague and not remotely like the the
small you know three four feet tall
grays
that i encountered
where the term skinny bob came from is a
strange terminology and oh and the word
is classified people are saying
that you were looking for the word that
starts with c
has this experience affected your
outlook on life
particularly with your relationship to
religion and spirituality
definitely definitely affected uh you
know you've got to come to some sort of
an understanding that's more universal
you know the fact that we have
um
denominations
within religions
and it's it's not just christianity it's
uh other arab and
eastern religions that have factions and
uh
ultimate truth
needs to be singular
to start with you know it's just
my biased thinking that's my personal
interpretation of it but uh
these are profound questions they're
we're talking about
all of creation the universe and so um
definitely needs to be compatible with
uh
um
common sense
um
you're seeking truth not just
something to uh
back up your your faction
let's talk about some of the visual
aspects of what happened when you were
abducted in 1975 so you mentioned that
visually they look like humans
and i believe on joe rogan you describe
him as wait a minute wait a minute
humanoid humanoid a humanoid does not
mean looking like people in that pass on
the street in
my town humanoid means two arms two legs
ahead on top eyes in front uh rather
than being looking like a large crab or
a
cockroach or something of that nature
so a lot of people have a
misconception uh but the grays are
humanoid and then there were other
beings that are if they were living
beings that were brought in in order to
interrupt my combativeness i was uh
fighting them and i think the effort was
to complete
uh healing or repairs that needed to be
made and i i was so terrified i wasn't
allowing that
so those people who were brought in this
who i'm referring to you said that they
look like people that would pass as
regular people just at the
in a cityscape you wouldn't be able to
point them out as being different
right
yeah and you know that of course would
uh
fulfill the purpose of getting me to
calm down and cooperate
so that's you thinking perhaps that's
the reason but you're not 100 sure that
if they were there
to be introduced to calm you as an
anxiolytic well it's possible that there
was some sort of ongoing
thing but it definitely changed the
direction of my efforts because
i was terrified of these creatures this
was
something i viewed as very threatening
and frightening and i wasn't about to
cooperate
now
um
many um
stories of encounters with these beings
describe them as being telepathic or
being able to
use mind control
but i i didn't sense anything of that
sort
but um i'm explaining that in my own
personal theory i can't say for sure of
course
is that being hit by that blast of
energy
uh impaired that connection you know
potentially
you're watching this channel because
you're interested in theoretical physics
consciousness and the ostensible
connection between the two what's
required to follow some of these
arguments is facility with mathematics
as well as discernment of the underlying
physical laws and you may think that
this is beyond you but that's false
brilliant provides pelucid explanations
of abstruse phenomenon such as quantum
computing general relativity and even
group theory when you hear that the
standard model is based on u1 cross su 2
cross su 3 that's group theory for
example now this isn't just for
neophytes either for example i have a
degree in math and physics and i still
found some of the intuitions given in
these lessons to vastly aid my
penetration into these subjects for
example electricity and magnetism sign
up today at brilliant.org
tow that is t-o-e for free you'll also
get 20 off the annual premium
subscription try four of the lessons at
least don't stop before four and i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you comprehend subjects you
previously had trouble grocking links
are in the description
do you think that some of the human
looking alien not humanoid the
i don't we need to give it a name so
that when i'm referring to it you know
what i'm referring to the human ones
that came in that were there
supposedly to calm you at least so those
ones do you think they were the grays
dressed up do you think they were a
projection did you get the impression
that they were robots
well it would probably would have taken
quite a bit of telepathic manipulation
to make these smaller creatures appear
to be the human looking ones so i'm
thinking um
they were either really were just earth
people that were cooperating with this
species
or were a creation that they came up
with in order to
get me to cooperate
when they were doing what they did to
you whatever it was did you get the
sense that it was routine like they've
done this many times before and so they
were cold and distant
no
the lack of communication in hindsight i
think was because
um
telepathic communication was not
possible
in the um
injured state of my entire body
including my brain
and
wasn't because they didn't want to it's
just
i was not
in the position to
you know receive or
or
communicate i was basically screaming
like a crazy man so um that's nothing
that encourages conversation
paul wash asks travis given that you've
suffered for 45 years of obviously
difficult trauma what would you say to
your captors if you were given the
opportunity to read from a victim impact
statement lifelong fan by the way so
that's paul wash basically what would
you say if you could communicate to the
aliens
well i i would say the number one thing
at the top of the list would be
why
you know to have an explanation so much
of what i'm telling you is my own
speculation that the kind of conclusions
i come to to come to terms with this but
this is you know after 40 some years of
thinking about it
what's the most recent paranormal
paranormal-esque event you've
experienced
per i'm including ufo sightings as the
paranormal whether or not you want to
use that term you understand what i mean
well
um
i try to stick to the things i can
document
some
pretty impressive things in my personal
life but uh you know without
any documentation it's just a claim
i even
tend to shy away from telling people
about
uh extremely unusual
things i discover in the
world you know scientific facts a little
unknown animals and surprising sorts of
things because
they think it's attention seeking and
they think it's just an exaggeration if
they're the kind of person who doesn't
want to believe what i have to say don't
everything's conventional everything's
normal that's what that's what people
who say there is no other life outside
of planet earth that is what they crave
so
so deeply is certainty
that we don't have to consider the fact
that there are literally trillions of
planets
in our own solar system
um certainly billions of them
are likely to be earth-like and
i don't know it's it's terrifying for
some people or maybe they like feeling
special
and i've i actually you know
asked people before so when you go
outside at night and you look up at the
sky
and you see
all these millions of stars
you think that the creator just put them
there to decorate our night sky just
twinkle at us
and they uh
either say
imply that they actually think that or
they just duck the question
i think the claim would be not that i
believe this but i think the claim would
be that there exists life on other
planets but that's a different matter
that's a different matter than if
they've come here to inspect us or for
some other reason
well certainly and um there's even
physics claims that you can't travel i
mean um you look at the nearest star and
it's so many
light years away that conventional
travel would mean that even at the speed
of light they would have to take that
many years to get here
but give me a break
you know humans are just toddlers on the
scene
you go back just a few hundred years and
the most technological thing we have is
fire
and uh
to presume you know these people can't
see that now we have cell phones that
they're probably
things a lot more unexpected and not
fitting with conventional thought on the
subject
um
might be in our future
um
we talk about
human history of a few thousand years
of anything
very complex
and uh to presume that in
a thousand a thousand no two thousand
ten thousand
what about half a million
so the age of these star systems
the age of these stars and solar systems
that exist out there
uh it is so
great
that
the degree to which they're advanced
over us in terms of physics and
understanding
of science uh to make flat
pronouncements i mean it happened you
know lord kelvin he uh
he was the inventor of the kelvin
temperature scale he was quite uh an
intellectual respected
scientist and he
proclaimed that
humans would never travel faster than
i forget 30 miles an hour
or the uh all the air would be sucked
out of the conveyance and all the people
would die so you know he he predicted
nobody would go any faster than that but
there's
uh
as a matter of fact stan friedman
prominent uh scientist uh nuclear
physicist
wrote a whole book called science was
wrong
recording the various pronouncements
that the experts of the day said this is
the limit
and i'm up against that myself so who am
i i'm not a nuclear physicist
daniel rayson here says as a witness
myself i'm glad this man is brave enough
to take the ridicule for the rest of us
now tim yousubov says travis you
described ship controls in some
interview how did you get to that room
and how long did you stay there
i just ran there because of the uh my i
might resume my combativeness my threats
towards these creatures
they left and i just went seeking a way
out
so when i entered that area that i only
presume to be controls
i have no no
uh i'd uh
confirmation that anything i was doing
was actually moving the ship i didn't
feel it move
um
what was the question again
sure they want to know how did you get
there and how long did you stay there
for in this larger room oh well it was
just moments
and perhaps this um button pushing
attempting to open the door when i
didn't know where the ship was it was at
an airless place uh i didn't even know
but i was in hysterical panic and doing
things that were probably unwise
and i was uh
encountered this human looking being who
led me out of there so it was only just
minutes
you also mentioned you went down a ramp
to get from the initial room to the to
the second larger room can you describe
the ramp was it smooth was it gray were
there steps on the right it was um
this i was mainly concerned with where
they were taking me so i i was paying
attention to that and my other
surroundings but the ramp itself
was not slippery
fortunately because it was steeper than
you would normally
consider comfortable to be descending
um
nothing's special just a ram did it open
or was it already open
it was already open
and
i like detail so please entertain me for
this as it's coming down or it was
already down were there hinges that
allowed it to come down that you saw or
was it just i don't know i didn't see it
in motion but
i
did not see it moving
close to open
um the door that opened would probably
would have triggered that if if it
weren't already down it could have been
a section of the craft that merely
slid down and
took a different position
um i doubt it was something that just
came out of the floor in the hangar area
mp wants to know what does travis think
about the contact event in south africa
and about the visitors messages about
the harm and dangers of technology
have you heard of this
well i i
have heard various claims and you know
they told me to tell you this uh i like
i say i don't
evaluate anyone else's
case
but it's just
pure simple wisdom you know that humans
had better wise up
we cannot go
on
at this rate
when i was a kid
uh the population of earth
was half what it is today
and do we need to go another uh 40 years
and double again
and just keep doubling and doubling and
doubling um
there these are limits
there are limits to growth you can't go
on
forever multiplying greater and greater
and greater there's something
more conscious and more aware needs to
be done so much of what's being
extracted from the earth
is
finite
fossil fuels are fossil i mean are we
going to go back into a big
swamp age and and create a whole bunch
more petroleum under the ground no
no when they get it all pumped out of
the ground
uh they're gonna have to think well now
what are we gonna uh
lubricate our skateboards with or
whatever you know um
it's um
it's
and there was a musician when i was a
kid
um the sun name of the album was after
the gold rush
and that's what
humanity's expansion across this planet
has been a gold rush
you know charging headlong exploiting
everything right and left and
it's it's decimated so much of uh
what was
abundant and
natural and
we're gonna miss
it john doe wants to know do you recall
anything particular about the eyes of
the beings so both either the humanoid
ones or the more human-like ones they're
eye-calling oh yeah there was something
odd about the human-looking ones in
terms of their eyes
and i never quite put my finger on that
because like i say i wasn't studying
things out
something
unusual
and
one thing that stands out to me
concerning the grays was um
um
the stare
it seemed to be penetrating in a very
uncomfortable way
and um
but there were blinks at times
and a lot of people report no blinking
but uh no eyelids but there was
definitely blinking in this case
blinking with their own eyelids or with
the film that came up and then
disappeared like a lizard
it was like their own eyelids
and you know on eyes that size it was
quite a
pronounced sort of thing
their eyes
is it primarily black or were you able
to see a direction that they were
looking because there's some white
um
i i didn't see things
like a pupil or anything like that i
presume of course that they were looking
at me because
their faces were pointed towards me
fox into bush wants to know
now that you've been through this
experience do you have advice in case
someone else is in this a similar
situation
let's take that two ways so one is that
they're taken aboard okay and then also
the post abduction
media frenzy so how
what advice
would you give yourself let's say let's
just take it
to be you
what would you do differently in both
cases on the ship and then afterward
well those are two completely different
questions but um
the um decision to approach
and therefore you know sort of trigger
what happened
uh was something i regret and wish i
hadn't happened
uh it's too much to handle
um
as far as how to respond to uh
what happened afterwards
afterwards it was mostly negative
and over the years it's
it's uh evolved there's
there is
a lot of more positive
people recognizing things that they
have themselves experienced but
also um
still some negative because people
who might mistakenly consider it
a threat to things they already believe
have you met any people that have had
similar experiences to you
yes
are any of them people who
have public names that you can reference
well i think we already went through
this are there people that i'm going to
vouch for without having investigated
their case and
i'm sorry i'm just not going to do that
because then all there's many many
people and some of them are friends
that uh well why not put me on that list
you know it's just
it's way too political okay how about
this what was similar about the
experiences and what was different
without divulging who the people were in
particular
well i i would say the idea of being
blasted by uh some
form of energy that may have killed me
would be a unique feature but i've gone
to a great deal of time to try to
analyze what that was so much of what
made them call it an abduction rather
than the term i
i now prefer which is ambulance call
is that this blast of energy was an
accident took years of research to find
out that the
area where we were there
is one of the highest frequency of
lightning strikes of any place
in the united states
and that this
the presence of this craft or the field
it generates may have triggered a
discharge of energy
with me as the um
the ground wire
uh something kind of unexpected
and that sort of contributes to what
were they doing there
were they there to take one of us one of
the other crewmen alan dwayne
steve
um
no i don't think that was part of the
deal i think um
i and this is pure speculation
that this high frequency of lightning
strikes has to do with the fact that
when lightning strikes the earth
crystals are formed that are not formed
geologically
they're rare but quite exotic in terms
of the properties that they are you know
said to have
and it's called phobia right
so
it could have been something along the
lines of
um they're
looking
prospecting for fault right
so you think the high density of
lightning strikes
is the precipitator of the ufos or that
the ufos induce the high lightning
strikes
i would say the the first the former uh
that
the ufos
uh may be in that area because of the
high frequency of lightning and the
creation of these exotic crystals
speculation of course uh to understand
i'm not saying i know that i don't mind
speculation man i'm a fan of it
personally so six pool says can travis
describe what the graves were wearing if
any what was the material made of can he
discern any
well that's it
well um
they um
were wearing coveralls loose fitting
coveralls
of a
orangish brown color
soft velour
not shiny
um
i didn't pick up any details other than
that
do you happen to know how long the
duration is that you remember
inside the craft like is it you remember
only a minute that would just be an
estimation the the conscious period
was
um
you could you could you know take it off
in terms of you know
um
minutes and hours or that sort of thing
but certainly nothing that fills up five
days
and that is
or was um
a blank for me for so long what was the
state of your body because i imagine
that if you were not eating for five
days you would look drastically
different
were you
do you feel like you were fed somehow
uh must have been according to medical
tests uh they say that if your body is
feeding on itself that it generates
what's called ketones
and those were absents
although
uh there was evidently quite a bit of
dehydration
um
i was weighed
uh immediately after the incident as
soon as my brother got me back to my
mother's house
and then
by the time i went into dr kandel's
office
bringing those same scales with me
uh there was a recovery of at least five
pounds so
um just from hydration
just probably hydration i was very
thirsty that was so
um major point in
me describing how i felt a five pound
difference from when you arrive naked
you're weighing yourself correct
i wasn't naked that's hollywood but uh
from the time i was recovered from the
phone booth
uh to the time i was in the doctor's
office the following money the five
pounds sounds quite significant so i'm
wondering if any of that
difference was because of clothing
change where was there a difference in
clothing between your initial
measurement and then
well
no because i was way naked both times
so you just said that something was
hollywood that the naked was
only an artifact of hollywood
yeah
yeah they they filmed a bunch of other
nudity in that movie that didn't get
used fortunately but uh
it's just kind of one of those things
that hollywood tends to do i'm
interested in a remake that doesn't
resort to such devices
okay so sorry i want to make sure i'm
understanding this so
in hollywood they
falsely presented you as naked on a
scale
naked on the floor of the phone booth i
see okay okay but
you are way
naked yes when i came back to the house
my brother removed the clothes sealed
them up in a sealed bag
and
weighed me and uh i changed clothes
when you were scanned were there any
abnormalities someone here is asking if
you had an x-ray and there was
a device in you or a small piece you
mentioned that there was a grain well i
mentioned the small calcified granuloma
which is no longer there on any x-rays
also an actual brainwave scan
uh barrow's neurological institute is
where this was done
and this was where muhammad ali
moved to phoenix just to be near this
hospital
and the technician was not told who i
was he wasn't attaching any significance
to a description of what happened i was
actually put in there under a false name
so it was a double-blinded uh
examination
and they found uh what was described
i have still have the report
as a
bi-synchronous alternating wave
traveling from front to back
and i have undergone
subsequent
scans that did not show that
so i'm thinking it could have just been
an artifact of recent injury that was in
the process of healing
what's this wave what is the consequence
of it what does it mean by synchronous
alternating so both hemispheres were
the technician didn't say this this
shows that he was hit with electricity i
would love to uh
see uh scans
um
electro encephalograph done on people
who might have been hit by lightning or
maybe an electrician who stood up under
a live wire or something like that at
least something of that nature to see if
this kind of a pattern
is a feature of certain types of injury
or impact with
large amounts of energy or force did
they tell you anything else about that
particular brainwave pattern here's an
example there's something called alpha
waves and then there's theta waves i'm
sure you've heard of this
and they correspond to different
feelings of consciousness or different
modes like one is a more meditative mode
another others more cognitive thinking
creative mode
so what's the significance of this
wave that they found on you
maybe none but uh i'm just telling you
that you know people say what did the
test reveal and this is what came out
this technician
had no idea what i'd been through and
what
what i was being tested for it was just
something that he observed without
being told to look for something of that
sort
so it was just um
something that came up and maybe
insignificant
um i mean good grief we i don't know
anything about eegs what if what if just
being uh
um hysterical for five days uh you know
uh
could make you have an eeg of a certain
characteristic
but uh i don't know
i'm just saying if there is any
significance to that i'll have to go
back and read that eeg again and uh
see if they were referring to uh theta
waves alpha waves any of that sort of
thing do you have a pen and paper in
front of you
within arm's reach yeah
remember i said that i love details
do you mind showing me some of the
lines on the screen because as you were
describing them i can't visualize what
you're saying you're saying there's some
lines and lines coming off but there are
no markings
to indicate certain positions
well i'm no artist but uh
this screen
you saw it
where within
the ship
uh it was mounted on the arm of the of a
chair
um
it's just long uh lines
with short lines
but they didn't have numbers on each of
the little
short lines
and they would move in response to
things i did yeah i see it but
didn't reveal any information to me i
mean
so they moved in response to you you
didn't get the sense that that was a map
of something else it actually was
congruent with your emotions so when you
turned
the signals changed
well that's a possibility too
what else is common between your
experience and some of the other people
who you're not going to name but
the ones that you personally find
credible you said that there are some
commonalities so what's another one
well um
i had an experience when i was a small
child
i can't document it my brothers and
sisters remember this i'm telling them
at the time it happened i was telling
this happened and they said no it was a
dream but i never confused any dream
with reality or any such thing never
anything of this sort so
it was a very real experience encounter
a single being
um
that
was like a gray
i didn't call it an alien i just said it
was a little man with the bald head and
big eyes
and um
he was dressed in a black suit
and i thought that was interesting
because i found out later that
betty hills
beings were dressed in black suits
it was nighttime where the lights off
yeah we were all sleeping um
it was a huge house and um
in phoenix uh
cooled by evaporative coolers
so during the hottest part of the year
we would
make bed rolls lay in the hallway where
this giant cooler came down the hallway
and cooling us all off and uh so i woke
up because i felt my
legs being lifted
someone had picked up the bottom of the
blanket
and that woke me up it's not like oh i'm
dreaming an alien is coming no it was a
small man and i didn't know
what was lifting me until i looked to
see what was lifting me in
this little guy and i started to call
out and he dropped and ran off
when you were young you would describe
it as a little man now thinking back
is it the same type of entity that you
saw on this ship
or do you not have a great recollection
of it
i'd say it was very similar if not the
same as the people on the ship a small
man bald head very
pale chalky skin
uh huge eyes
and
dressed in black but i i didn't call it
an alien never did i just was insisting
to
this description to my brothers and
sisters and to this day they remember me
the only time i ever said this really
happened and they were saying it was a
dream but see that's that's one of those
stories that people are going to say oh
he's just
uh
living here you know
no uh
i would i i don't have
um
20 witnesses here
it's just something i'm not concerned
with
with skeptics
i i want to know
a bit more about the commonalities we
were talking about so you just talked
about your own experience again now when
you spoke with other people who have had
similar experiences to yourself what's
similar is what i'm curious
about
is this going to get turned into
travis's endorsement of some cases and
rejection of others no you don't have to
mention any names
well it still you know it boils down to
that eventually but uh you know there's
definitely a connection that
and a style of presentation and them
recalling what happened and describing
it
um
other kinds of subtle sorts of things
and i don't want to give anybody a list
of things
to to
add to their next story but uh
definitely
certain things that
bring a bell
and uh
not just in the experience itself not
just in the experience itself but
in the way
they related it to people and the way
people related to them
there seems to be a
commonality
what do you mean in the way that they
relate it is similar what do you mean
i don't want to go there come on man
i can't i can't do that to people
um i was immersed mercilessly um
parentally read and and criticized and
uh all this all this stuff uh
well that that doesn't match this
doesn't match that and it all come back
to
get the facts you don't even you didn't
even research my case you know people
are making criticisms and analyzing what
happened and they don't even know what's
been said and what actually happened
like you know a debunker who says well
travis was never at that phone booth he
was always
in his mother's cabin or something
if they do their research duh
they know
that the operator listened in on the
call and notified the sheriff
he sent up uh people over there to uh
take
fingerprints
so
there's all kinds of things where oh
those guys were out there hallucinating
on drugs no
a law enforcement entity
took samples from my body immediately
afterwards not one trace of any drug
whatsoever so um these kinds of it's
easy to just wipe it away with the back
of your hand
seven people don't have the same
hallucination
detail
identical
the the idea that it was um
a hallucination induced by
earthquake lights you know
the rim there is a
is
a giant fault in the ground so the
theory
that people were offering was that
earthquake lights
are what generated this blast of energy
which actually came out of me and went
right to a craft
but but anyway that went through my
brain and made me hallucinate well
the guys in the truck 90 feet away um
they didn't
uh they weren't touching the ground and
and how could a blast of earthquake
lights uh affect them
and more importantly why would all seven
of us
imagine the same thing
people are really reaching when they
grab for these ways of trying to explain
it away
but there's
quite a variety to them and
we're serious
juanita grand
grand wants to know i recall him talking
about the temperature and dryness of the
air inside the craft i would like to
know if he's noticed anything else
strange obviously there's plenty strange
but something else that you haven't
spoken much about if not at all not
really just uh
i was
feeling injured and so maybe
the suffocating feeling came from that
but
um the the human looking
being who took me out of there was
wearing a helmet on his head so that was
probably
i would think to protect him from the
atmosphere in there
or maybe to
avoid contaminating the interior of the
craft i don't know but um it does
suggest that
perhaps that was the reason
it did feel immediately cooler
and easier to breathe as soon as we got
outside
outside the initial room whereas you
could still be inside the craft into the
larger hanger room
see to me when i'm visualizing this i
only think in terms of craft so i think
in terms of this is a small craft inside
a larger craft but the way you're
describing it is this it's as if it's a
blue or a craft inside of a large
building somewhere it could be just a
hanger on the ground somewhere
if you had to make a guess as to how
large it was how many feet away could
you see your meters how large would you
characterize it well before i quote a
figure i really ought to get meditate on
that a bit you know figure out what the
size would be it was quite a bit larger
big enough for these things to fly into
i would assume they flew in there i
didn't see them flying
i know you said you need to think about
it some more
more than four times the size of the
initial place
is that correct
yeah
more
i'm a man of details travis but more
than 10 times
i would say you know
got to be bigger than 200 feet you know
if there's
a couple of craft in there 40 feet in
diameter
um that adds up to 80 but they're spaced
by maybe 30. you know i'm just off the
top of my head saying
a figure like that
mj jumps wants to know before you die
will you reveal if you've had any other
contact with ets or ufos
well that would be like admitting that i
had it so
that's a loaded question sneaky way
around the question
how about this is there more to come
from travis walton
yes yeah i think so
someone wants to know about high
strangeness it's this term that keeps
coming up over and over which i'm sure
you're familiar with
have you experienced any high
strangeness after your event
yeah but it wasn't witnessed by multiple
witnesses so
well
now see i could i sense such reservation
on your part and i imagine that's
because you've been
excoriated to such a degree that you
don't want
that it hurts you to be criticized even
a little bit or at least for people to
look at you with skeptical eyes
is that the main reason that you don't
like to talk about what can't be
corroborated
yeah i i'm interested in making people
understand that this is a real
phenomenon that this really happened in
anything like what happened to me that
one night well no one else uh but my
family knew uh um
to to people that want to find a reason
to disbelieve they're going to think of
that as an embellishment or some sort of
a an attention getter it's something
that really happened and
the family whole family verifies it but
that's not that's not enough witnesses
to qualify
um
in today's world
what other items did you see on the
craft so you mentioned a rod that was a
glass
that you took and you started swinging
well those other instruments were not
anything i would recognize
i didn't look like uh i'm familiar with
tools
and some medical instruments
uh i was actually
eventually
certified as an emt
i took the state test
on
midwifery
and uh it was offered by this state of
arizona
to bring all of the
lay midwives in
you know many who had been practicing
under doctors for years
into an official licensing situation
so the offer was come in take this test
and uh
it was just a spur-of-the-moment thing i
didn't plan it i only heard about it a
couple of days before the test
went in and
i got the second highest score out of
the whole group
but uh
maybe it's a
genetic thing i don't know my father was
a doctor
actually an obstetrician
can you draw some of what you saw in
terms of the devices that
you can't recognize or you can't places
just a comment quick glance what what's
the biggest thing here what can i use
for a weapon
that's all um
there was a thing that looked
kind of like a
i'm sorry
this is that time of day when i get
robo calls
do you mind turning off the ringer
putting it on silent
someone okay so cloud in seattle wants
to know has travis ever tried ce5 since
the incident and if so what were his
takeaways
what is
what's that i don't know because people
keep mentioning ce5 so if those in the
comments can let me know what ce5 is
then i can i don't know travis know okay
so i probably didn't try it uh
is that a type of hypnosis is that uh is
he the reason why it's taken me a while
to come up with questions is because
not only am i reading some of the
audience questions but i'm
i want to ask you
i want to ask you more details about
these
beings but i don't want you to
be on the defensive because i'm not a
i'm not a debunker i'm not a skeptic
i'm on your side or at least
i'm not against you i appreciate that
but you know
the audience is huge and anybody that
wants to take something and turn it into
something that's not uh
theirs are actually few and far between
but there's
people like that
do you think that these
that these people the ones with helmets
that calmed you
that were there or at least you think
were there to calm you do you think that
they walk among us
have you seen any strange people
yeah i actually said that that they
would pass in a crowd you wouldn't go
whoa there's that kind of odd looking
robotic human or something like that
no i think that they would pass in a
crowd yeah have you seen any people but
you said that they gave you a strange
feeling at least with their eyes it
wasn't
there's something not right about their
eyes
have you encountered any people like
that i never could put my finger on
exactly what it was
color the way they
the pupil constricts or whatever i i
don't know but just something
a little unusual about that so ce5 is a
term describing the fifth category of
close encounters with extraterrestrial
intelligence characterized by mutual
bilateral communication rather than
unilateral contact
so did you communicate with them
well i stick to the stuff i can document
so
nothing to report there
that's i know that's disappointing
people love
there's so many people that have had an
experience and they'll
expound on whatever
but
how do these alien creatures feed
themselves have you had any thoughts on
that now this question comes from henry
bong
well that's a
you know an interesting question people
would love to know that but
uh i didn't see their kitchen and we
were
not in any sort of a situation on how i
was fed if i was or how they feed
themselves or don't know
that's just a
complete unknown
okay david reed says
first of all travis respect you for
sticking with your story i myself have
witnessed
a ufo in majorca in september 1995. i've
only discussed it with my wife question
considering how long it took you to come
to terms with come to terms with your
experience do you think that the human
race is ready to accept for some time
now that we've been observed by
technologically advanced intelligence
i do think that uh humans are getting
closer and closer to that this whole
big lead up to a big
release of information from in congress
was sort of a
letdown it wasn't uh
as forthcoming as it was promised but i
the fact that it existed at all is a
major step forward
and um
basically
to uh have official channels acknowledge
that there
is something there that isn't ours and
uh
um
whether they just uh
their conscience got to them they
decided to come clean and tell us i i
don't think that's the case it was just
a matter of
the evidence is piling up too high to
rely on ridicule and dismissing the
witnesses
was not
reducing their credibility it was
reducing the government's credibility
so they
you know finally acknowledge yes there's
things we can't
explain in terms of uh
conventional
whatever so that was a step forward and
you know it's interesting it was kind of
a
social engineering kind of a thing
that when these announcements were made
they came late on a friday
and that's normally what
they do
when um
they want to
something to be out there but to get
a minimum of attention
uh it sort of gets ignored until the
next news cycle and by monday there'll
be a whole pile of other things to
divert attention so it doesn't
doesn't uh
it's a
a soft bombshell
going back to your childhood
you said that there was this alien or at
least a little man you weren't sure what
it was at the time
and it was wearing black
now
the ones on this ship were wearing a
light blue if i recall
what's that material is it no no
orangish brown
okay so they're wearing orange
slash brown
what type of material is it did could
you see that they're wearing clothing
for example with me you could see a bit
of a shadow from a light it was
extremely tight fitting
but you were able to tell it was
clothing because it was a different it
was different than their skin color
it was loose fitting and
sort of billowy a little bit but um
uh weaveless i didn't see uh
grain in a fabric is more like velour
but uh i was riveted on the eyes i
wasn't
thinking about you know
what are these clothes made out of or
that kind of thing you know
all of us think wow if we were in that
kind of an opportunity
to you know learn these things that's
the sort of thing we'd be uh um
i'm sorry i i tried to turn this thing
off but it just
that's all right that's all right that's
what i said hello moto which is what it
normally does when i turned off okay
that's all right vox vesper wanna know
did you at any point during your oh i'm
gonna stick this thing under the
mattress
sure did you at any point during your
abduction experience have a feeling of
ecstasy so this comes from vox vesper
no
no it was terrifying and painful
but i was injured you know so
it doesn't have anything to do with
trying to enjoy the experience
tim yousubov wants to know could you
talk more about what the ship lighting
was
at the other facility i assume he means
when you entered into the larger room
well
looking like
gentle sunlight
nothing to describe is just normal
lighting normal the colors of looking at
my uh
you know self and
things around me
there wasn't any unusual cast of things
randall mattel wants to know do you
think the beings you encountered were
just another aspect of the craft itself
i'm not sure what the question means
but uh
i i don't i don't understand the
question
were the craft generating beings is that
what they're saying yes like projections
or perhaps somehow these beings are
integrated within the craft was there a
difference between there's obviously a
difference between the craft and the
beings but did you get a sense that
there was an intimate tie between them
well i didn't i didn't get any feeling
other than pain and fear uh
sorry i wasn't wasn't all tuned in and
spiritual but uh
i
all those kinds of things could exist
but i
i wasn't experiencing that way
jason brown wants to know please ask
travis if there was any physical
evidence in the area the craft
interacted with him i recall you talked
about tree rings but what else
yes definitely uh there was initially
magnetic readings that were taken
scanning across the clearing taking
measurements
and
charting it all out
and
the report was that there was a polarity
reversal in the direction the craft had
departed
i uh
never got to see this evidence i would
love
to um
i believe the the the
ufologists that were taking the reading
um
were from uh something no i i can't say
for sure who who it was but it was it
was uh recognizable names in ufology
but um
there was also a report later
that
later that summer a volunteer in the
fire watch
reported that there was a government
team that came through
taking magnetic readings on the ground
and she just found that curious because
normally
such readings would be
taken from an instrument suspended under
an airplane but uh
they were doing it directly on the
ground in the area
um
maybe no connection at all but
she saw the team and
asked him what they were doing
i could go back and ask her more about
what they might have told her because
she was a reporter for the local paper
if you still are in contact with her be
great if you could
and then you could just email me also
okay dynamite biz quits wants to know
ask him if the gravity was the same
or different when you woke up so on the
craft did you notice that you were able
to run quicker or slower
good question
i felt
heavy
like i could barely make myself move it
took
it took the adrenaline of panic to be
able to
do the things i did
but i took
mistook or whatever interpreted that
weakness to be
something to do with my injury
the improvement in my energy level and
everything when i got outside the craft
um could could uh indicate that there
was heavier gravity generated inside
that craft for some reason
um
if the beings in their home planet uh
have a heavier gravity it would also
contribute to a denser atmosphere
more my speculation after 40 years a
denser atmosphere perhaps cutting down
on the amount of light reaching the
surface
of the planet
which might explain
the large eyes large eyes have got to
mean
either of
some kind of an environment where light
is limited i would think
um are they nocturnal maybe that would
be the reason but
if they aren't nocturnal then perhaps
the large eyes come from living
where the atmosphere is heavy denser and
less light reaches the surface
did you notice any strangeness or
anything abnormal about how the aliens
walked so firstly did you see the gray's
walk
yes and it was just a real quick light
scurrying um they actually so you know
when i was made contact with one of them
with the back of my arm
it was a lot lighter than i expected it
fell back
very easily
so they just scurry i know that some
people say that they move they shuffle
like
like cicada or like some insect
did you notice any strange movement i
didn't get any insects like compressions
at all was there a difference between
how the greys moved versus the more
human-like
beings
the human-looking ones moved like humans
and
the
grays just moved like
very light quick
beings
considering the ufo radiation could have
killed you have you ever thought that
they grabbed you to heal you this one
comes from benito
yeah definitely because the evidence of
radiation in the trees
would suggest that i
would
myself have been exposed to a large
amount and that could have been part of
what the treatment was or maybe quite a
lot of it i don't know
and
one other thing is that
the crewman that was sitting to my left
when i got out of the truck i left the
door open
and he did develop skin cancer on his
right forearm which
would been probably the most
exposed part of his whole anatomy
but again it could be
a coincidence
can you talk some more about how this
has affected your view on death and god
this comes from i jazz sweat
well
if you were a really super highly
technological
civilization
and had
understanding of life prosperous far
beyond
anything
that we have
you would think one of the
priorities would have been
to eliminate disease especially aging
so that's a speculation on my part but i
would think that perhaps that's an
indication that they're extremely
long-lived and maybe even
uh long-lived enough to tolerate
uh
years of flight to get here if that were
necessary
what do you make of cali waldrip who
said that you concocted an
abduction story
and i'll just read this quote i happened
across your referring to michael shermer
your assessment
of travis walton's alleged abduction
aboard a ufo in 1975. your suspicion
that it was a hoax is completely correct
i know these you can respond to this
shortly travis and i were in junior high
school back together
together back in the early 60s and he
was constantly dreaming up schemes to
deceive folks
that a ufo was visiting
i haven't seen him in decades and
i reminded him of that in 2006 via email
he changed the subject
i found the online bio
suggesting that we weren't in the same
grade school were the same age but his
bio lists him five so there's various
assertions there how would you respond
to that
like i say people who knew you are eager
to say i've got the inside story
well
he's got some
amazing tales um
himself
he was my best friend
and
it was actually his idea to
put up a hot air balloon or something
but uh
he became an fbi agent
and uh
the only contact i've had with him was
years ago and he was describing how he
was basically
um
ducking and dodging around the planet to
avoid being assassinated in connection
with his previous work his previous job
well maybe it's true sounds kind of wild
though
but uh he's definitely exaggerating
anything that was said between us
like i said people love to get attention
uh
i know this guy you know i'll tell you
the inside story
you know he's not in a position to add
anything positive so it's great to
attack your best friend but uh whatever
you two had a falling out
no we just um you know i moved
to a different city you called him your
best friend
you mean prior or even now
during our during our junior high years
you know we hung out together all the
time but uh i guarantee you ufos were
not a constant topic of conversation you
mentioned something about a hot air
balloon
um
this is something he's saying
that i said but uh i only remembered him
suggesting such a thing
but uh
it's terrible somebody would come out
there and attack you like that
do you think that he just wants fame
himself or money or what
well just like i said you know i'm the
guy that's gonna i got the inside story
i know this person you know
it's like the guy who says i called him
first before i called my family
it's um in that case not attempting to
do any harm just to attach yourself
to something that's got a lot of
attention i mean there were three or
four girls that i had dated who had some
stories to tell when everybody's talking
about that guy
and uh
things that weren't true
and this
email communication he references in
2006
he said he brought it up to you
i'm unsure exactly what he's referring
to i assume he means
that you were quote-unquote trying to
deceive and so on but then you change
the subject do you know what he's
referring to
do you recall this
kelly waldrop
i'll just give you the quote he said i'm
actually reminded i reminded him of this
referring to what we just spoke about in
2006 via email and he simply changed the
subject not wanting to crack his golden
egg i suppose
that's what kelly said what i said was i
don't remember you had an idea like that
he was accusing me of an idea
um
but
like i say it's the same
same thing you know
he's using my prior friendship with him
to
elevate himself here
uh
does he in any way speak to
seven people passing police lie detector
test does he speak to
the effect of radiation on tree growth
does he uh you know any of those kinds
of things
the guy's an fbi agent or a former fbi
agent so he should um
resort to evidence and
the facts of the case
attack
let's address the facts when you can't
address the facts
attack the person so
that's what's happening does it hurt you
because he's a former friend of yours i
imagine that
if that was me i would be
not only offended but
saddened
or are you so used to it now
well
of course it's uh
it's sad you know and i'd always thought
about
contacting him
because i had heard some the story
second hand from somebody
that i worked with at the paper mill
that he had said something like that
and uh
kind of uh fell in him in on the details
don't be jumping to conclusions guy
but apparently he has
to each his own
eve clancy wants to know do you believe
yourself to have been abducted more than
once
it's possible but you know um
in any other case it would have been
something where you know memories are
blocked or something of that nature
where you're unconscious
bilbo baggins wants to know does travis
think the recent uaps
are related to the craft in his
experience or is it maybe a different
phenomenon so there's been plenty of uap
disclosure recently
there's a question i think that the
recent uap disclosures the ufos
associated with them are similar if not
the same to the one that abducted you or
the ones that you've seen
oh um
as far as you know these various reports
uh i don't think that the typical flying
saucer
uh is necessarily
the exclusive
form of these ships
um
some are spherical some are triangular
there's the tic tac shape that the
navy is filmed
so there's a variety of shapes there's
uh
other other shapes that are more hard to
describe long
long thin things
okay we're going to rap in about five
minutes so people please as you're
asking the questions just type in all
caps and please at me so that i can see
them easily
travis
you also talked about a low rumble as
well as a high-pitched noise when the
craft came near you do you mind
repeating and expanding upon it
well it was um
a frequency that's so low
you you felt it more than uh
heard it or
simultaneously
um
and then a really high high pitch to it
that
and i'm just talking about the ends of
the frequency of the
spectrum of sound
um
you also mentioned when the craft was
near there was some wind
uh wind yeah the trees were moving as it
or perhaps it was when the craft went
away your friends reported that the
trees oh wow the craft that left me off
uh
created a stir in the air as it passed
some small limbs close by but
that wasn't what you experienced that's
what your friends told you afterward
oh right but when the craft dropped you
off you were able to look and see when i
was dropped off i was the only
only person there do you well i assume
your friends may have been in too much
of a panic
to know if there was any strange
activity when the craft left such as
extreme wind or a special sound but
there were other witnesses that saw the
craft depart that reported it to the
sheriff
a man who said his
his job was military intelligence
deer hunting with his wife
still have the
see back in those days we didn't have
cell phones a lot of this communication
came in actual physical letters
and another one that came
um both to me and the sheriff
describing seeing the craft depart
from closer to black canyon lake which
is
near turkey springs
john doe wants to know ask if he thinks
it's strange that his buddy had the idea
of making up a ufo story when they were
young and then it actually happens to
him
so how do you respond to that
do you think it's strange do you think
it's a coincidence do you think it's not
coincidental i think it's an opportunity
it's an opportunity
now i don't know if he had to go
hide his name and and travel around the
world to avoid being assassinated by the
fbi that sounds like a pretty wild story
myself you know but uh maybe it's true
you know uh some of those characters up
there are
pretty um
um
unethical uh to
wants to know did it look like the other
beings were communicating with one
another in some way such as did they
look at one another i know they didn't
speak but did you sense any form of
talking anymore they did move
simultaneously
i didn't see any communication or hand
signal or anything so
it was also pretty apparent that i was
getting ready to attack them
fight my way past them to get to the
door
and so they turned simultaneously
and departed
freedom loving fool wants to know travis
could you see outside the craft could
you tell if you're underwater or ariel
no i couldn't tell i could not see
outside of whether i was underground
underwater or
outside the atmosphere
there was no window of that sort do you
think the ufo phenomenon has been used
for psychological warfare
what do you think of the threat
narrative that's being pushed in
mainstream this one comes from freedom
fighter
well i think
our governments um
world governments for that matter uh
take advantage of certain things that
occur in order to
shape
the behavior of populations that's
pretty common
and uh in today's world
they have a wealth of data
to
tap into
because
x happens and they almost instantly are
able to gather
information on huge numbers of people so
they can predict
the the outcome of certain things and
measure it in ways that gives them a
power of people who are truly
underestimating
do you get many people saying convince
me convince me of the fact that you were
abducted
i don't care
you know uh people are willing to listen
i will give them the facts if they want
to say oh i don't believe this no matter
what you know
uh
you know you you you claimed you saw uh
an uh ufo 20 years before that you know
okay fine that totally disqualifies me
if anybody sees a ufo just say all right
scratch me up the list
anything that happens from here on
no credibility no no nothing and that
includes not just seeing a ufo anything
um
uh seeing a uh beating in the park or
something of that nature uh well
oh come on this is a guy who said he saw
ufo this is a guy who just thinks he saw
aliens forget him you know
really there's a part of me that you
know has
often thought just walk away from all
this and just
you know
what would you do don't talk about it
what in your fantasies when you think
about walking away are you going to an
island and then drinking from coconuts
what are you doing
uh just refusing to respond to
inquiries
requests for interviews or appearances
and
now that should be enough for a while
that they're not going to get anything
out of me i got nothing to say
dynamite biz quits wants to know do any
pictures that you've seen look like
what you saw
so have you seen movies that closely
resemble the greys or have you seen
images well yeah generally speaking um
you know of any resemblances i would
have to say that the craft that
bazaar
described
and
authorized a model with the plastic
model with the tear stairs corporation
is the closest to the craft we
encountered in the woods
but um like i said these craft have many
different shapes and forms and
if you see more than one you're crazy
lunatic anyway
have they done any testing on the
clothing that you had for radiation
no
once the bag got tore open and it was
considered contaminated that
i even kept them
for a while
in the shed and they got further
contaminated after that
so you still have them but they're just
contaminated
well i did for a while i don't know
where they are now
stefan
exodus wants to know are you amazed or
surprised that even after all these
years and that you've never changed your
story that people still ask you about
your abduction
well it grows and grows and grows you
know more and more inquiries from
far-off places
some i've never heard of some i got to
check the map to see where that is but
um
it's kind of the purpose
to continue to talk about it is to let
people know simply
that it's real
um these giant black triangles i saw one
with other witnesses
15 or 20 actually at least i would love
to go back and
get the
addresses contact information of these
people and see if any of them took a
picture
because my son said dad dad you should
we pull over and take a picture i go no
no okay keep going and you know i was
surprised that i had so much ptsd after
that much time to to be scared to pull
over and take a picture i sure wish i
had but certainly you know 15 20 other
people reporting in
to one website
um
ufostalker.com i believe is the name of
it uh they would
you know get their addresses and see if
one of them just at least one took a
photo
is this the same triangle when you were
with your wife and your wife had a
who was pregnant is this the same one
and
someone asked and please if i'm
mispronouncing this name or miss saying
it rewrite it someone asked a while ago
did someone name steve
rear
not greer steve ride steve reed examine
your girlfriend
i don't know the doctor's name i was in
the in the room i saw the ultrasound but
i don't know her doctor's name i'm sure
she knows has always
no
yes maybe is roger lear the doctor
no he was not the the medical doctor who
examined her
he uh
was involved in researching the case
later
but
um
when
she passed the cord and the placenta
that was um time for the medical people
the scientists to come in and examine
and this claim that it was an alien or
that i said it was an alien it's just a
damn lie i've never said any such thing
but see again these are people who are
in a position to make up a story and
become an important part of something
that's worldwide news so yeah he said
one claim was that i killed the baby
that i performed an abortion on this
woman total lie
you know
uh
i am totally anti-abortion i don't care
who knows it uh
and i was uh trained as a midwife
uh as i said
second highest score out of 40 people
um
i would never in this world dream of
performing an abortion that's just
uh i've delivered a number of babies
uh
but uh
the claim that i
you know killed this baby because it was
half alien was just a wild claim gets
attention that's what it's that's what
it's all about
something that got the news is out there
get my two cents worth in look at me
look at me i knew travis in the past you
know
i dated my uh
with his friend or whatever
travis where can people find out more
about you
and what's next traviswalton.com
what's next for you
um
a um
big budget remake of fire in the sky
it's their idea and i'm all for it
because i'd love to straighten out a few
things you know there's some
misconceptions about what happened
uh
people have come to
um
based on
the movie i think the movie was a huge
accomplishment in terms of breaking down
people's resistance to the idea that it
could happen because they were sort of
vicariously able to live it themselves
but i always try to warn people don't
don't treat it as a documentary it was
entertainment
and
hollywood does that sort of thing so
i'm going to try to keep
retain
the script approval this time around
and tim has one last question travis do
you recall seeing any symbols signs or
writings on the walls floor ceilings
etc
good question but uh no no symbols of
any kind
no numbers no letters
or anything that would
suggest such a thing
all right man
take care and have a great night
well thank you the discussion with
travis has now concluded
and there's a five-minute addendum with
amjad hussein who has sponsored this
podcast via his company algo we're
cutting right into the middle of a
discussion we had on the topic of ufos i
wasn't sure
should i continue going down this path
and you said that you were interested in
ufos
what's your interest in them
yeah no first of all uh gary
one thing that i want to say is that
the way you
approach these topics and
connect with people
you have a way to
connect at a deeper
human level so that
definitely is a gift
gift that you have
uh that is how i got attracted
uh
to you and your podcast and
that genuine
curiosity
intellectual honesty and
and and going deeper and that was
and remains to be
my
excitement about
you and the brand and the gift i would
say that you bring up to
the universe my
fascination
uh
with ufos just come from
i am
curious and
uh
quite some time ago
you know uh
i watched this
carl sagan movie contact
and i uh
since then you know have been thinking
about that are there
[Music]
intelligent life
elsewhere and
whatnot
and then uh
for a while i was not very serious about
uh the
entire ufo phenomenon and whatnot
but then
some serious-minded people who have
other professional lives and careers who
were not out there hunting for ufos
like this navy command commander uh dave
forward i might be pushing his last
driver
when he started talking about his
observations and when they were on those
missions uh off of the coast of san
diego
i started saying to myself that look you
know there must be something to it he
has absolutely
nothing to gain no reasons to lie
he's so rational minded
he's a
trained trained
navy
pilot with all the training and he has
this training to keep his mind together
in extreme circumstances
so then for him to observe something
there must be something to that so that
is kind of how i got
started into that and then from there
i took it upon myself kurt just to
read
everything that is out there
good bad in between
putting my judgment aside
um and then i also learned in that
process that
in north america
ufology
is a
religion almost a new age religion as
well where you know
around
different phenomena
uh for different sightings
people have developed
you know
culture and curves and
rituals and
communities and societies and
uh and it seems
uh very sort of correlated with how
you know other ideas or
micro religions or communities develop
so i just found that very fascinating
that how
the ufology community
is very protective of their ideas and
how they come together
quite interestingly and totally
unrelated to the topic of ufology
uh there is these days this bitcoin
community and they are very protective
of the bitcoin religion and the bitcoin
ideas and all that stuff and they
if you ask questions they attack you
they are very very protective of
that sort of thing so i just find it
interesting to see how these communities
uh develop so there is no like you know
uh
deep answered as to how i got into ufos
but i just you know it
peaks my interest and it would be
awesome to find out that there are other
you know
beings
you know other forms of consciousness
and
can we learn something from them
those types of things i have heard
others talk about that
probably
if there is a phenomenon there is an
encounter
we are
encountering
some alien technology
or
their creations versus alien themselves
and the argument is that
if we send a probe out there and whatnot
it's very likely that somebody is going
to first run into a technology that
humans send out
uh or our space junk or you know what
have you uh but now it was just an
intellectual curiosity uh
when i saw those navy folks talking
about it i said well there must be
something to it i shouldn't just
just because i don't know anything about
it and the topic sounds too fringe to
absurd let's just totally discount it
without looking into it so i just
started
studying it that was sort of my uh
uh entry into
uh studying ufo and then i found that
all kind of people
from
scientists to religious philosophers and
people in between uh
you know are part of that are part of
that community
so what are your conclusions now
are you still formulating them
no there are no there are no conclusions
i think
a lot of people would say
uh
people who are a lot more uh curt
scientifically minded uh like even you
were talking to
a few months ago with avi lowe
and there are many others like avi who
you know avi is open to ideas of
hey um probably is you know not uh
nitrogen frozen nitrogen or some other
thing it is probably some alien
junk or alien technology or whatever so
he's open to i mean he has put his
career at risk in that sense uh but even
he said uh
nah you know when you asked him that
question regarding ufos he said well you
know there is no evidence for it you
know we should scientifically study it
so people who are a lot more
scientifically minded even the likes of
avi
they are not very
uh sort of you know
ufo
friendly they don't think that the
evidence
that is out there
convinces them enough uh so i always try
to say well can i you know look at what
people who are a lot more disciplined
and smarter about than i am what do they
think
so i yet have to find
real professional career scientists who
think that
that is the plausible explanation they
think other explanations you know are
plausible and possible and that kind of
a thing
so i am still
looking studying
uh searching i also heard think about it
that has it to do something with
consciousness and
uh psychedelic type experiences where
people
you know when they are under the
influence of bmt molecules or other
things like that they say well you know
i went there and i went here and i met
so and so and whatnot and uh
and then you know is there something
like a
shared consciousness or something like
that where there is a
network uh for conscious beings to come
together
uh because physics is physics even in
the uh uh the u.s navy sort of sightings
that hey you know
those
objects they were defying the
our physical reality well uh maybe that
means they you know uh
are
holograms or images of some sort or what
have you there is definitely something
to it
uh
so i think it needs to be just studied a
lot more and
that is what i would say so my quest uh
as a student
as a layperson
continues
thank you so much for watching if you'd
like to see more videos like this then
please do consider going to patreon.com
and supporting this podcast literally
each dollar helps i'm grateful for
whatever decision you make there's also
a paypal and a cryptocurrency option
links are in the description thank you
so much